before we get started this video is
brought to you by curiosity stream that
would be a streaming service that
nurtures curiosity through the power of
documentary videos we'll talk about them
a little later in the video but for now
let's talk about a movie 1917 the movie
not the year so 1917 is a World War one
epic directed by Sam Mendes Sam Mendes
is he's a talented director he did do
Spectre but he did that opening scene in
Spectre which is actually pretty sweet
which judging by this movie looks like
the beginning of Spectre was him dipping
his toe into the hole one shot feel and
he was like alright I'll just I'll just
make a World War 1 epic like that at the
story of 1917 it's a simple one British
soldiers are pushing the German troops
back however they're operating on old
Intel new Intel says the other walking
into a trap so these two average
soldiers are chosen to walk deep behind
enemy lines deliver the new orders that
say stand down you're walking into a
trap otherwise 1600 people will die
simple yes epic yes it's simple like the
story of Frodo and Sam is simple your
story is you got to go deep behind enemy
lines drop a ring into a volcano
simple yet epic which is funny because
we all know the stories apparently JRR
Tolkien's writings they were inspired by
his time in the war no tokens not in it
I'm just saying there's not just them on
the battlefield see this movie is filmed
to feel like it's one continuous shot
like Birdman style but on the
battlefields of World War one which
could have felt like a gimmick but for
the movie it does enhance the experience
it being one continuous shot it no
longer feels like it's a two-person
mission now it's three because you're
there too there's something about the
execution of how this movie was filmed
it like heightens your senses when they
stop and rest you're looking at the
hills like are there any enemies no
alright it's like you can't rest either
and if they're resting you're the eyes
not every war movie pulls that off this
movie does I firmly believe it's because
how it was filmed and it's not just one
continuous shot over the shoulder or
anything like that
now the cinematography is insane - this
is one shot where they go around it's a
pretty big puddle upon's
one could call it a pond but the shots
with them and then it gets down to water
level as they walk on the outside and it
just follows them across and the meets
back up with them on the other side
shots like that I'm like okay
he could have done it lazy you didn't
god there's movie epic that's the word
and this movie is a war movie that
doesn't rely on like carnage or anything
like that you don't need that in fact
there are very few gunfights in this
movie it's it's not about the firefights
you don't get the first part of Saving
Private Ryan in here at any point it's
just the movie is very intense I mean
there are a couple of shootouts when the
movie calls for a couple of shootouts
but even then it never gets to Hollywood
in that sense you don't feel like anyone
has unlimited ammo and really you're
playing defense the entire he's playing
defense the entire time he just wants to
escape and get out of there because
that's what that situation would be like
and it feels more intense because you
feel like you're there because the
movies massage do you into it it's
crafted itself to lend itself into you
projecting yourself into it there was
one part in here something startling
happens and I was like I almost had a
[ __ ] heart attack in most other
movies I'd be like okay the thing
happens this one I was like good huh is
everyone all right
it just it was I hadn't really felt like
that in a war movie next level but this
movie just succeeded on all fronts it
has a couple of very relatable
characters one in particular completely
carries this movie it puts you with them
behind enemy lines at the level I
haven't seen in a war movie in a very
long time it's beautifully shot the
two-hour one-shot feel doesn't feel like
a gimmick completely works for the movie
the story is simple in nature because we
all just kind of get the need to save
lives let epic and execution it's
emotional it has the fields 1917 is
awesome tacular
it doesn't come out until Christmas in
select theaters and I guess it doesn't
come out until January 10th nationwide
but if you have the opportunity to watch
19:17 do watch it as I said earlier in
this video this video is brought to you
by curiosity stream curiosity stream is
the world's first subscription streaming
service offering thousands of
documentary videos and as I've said
before I enjoy me a good documentary
multiple videos if you got them and they
actually have multiple documentary
videos on war itself one in particular
called apocalypse world war one that
actually uses colorized historical
footage of world war one there's
something about adding color to
historical footage it helps bring it
from separated reality to reality at
least for me and I appreciate that
so click the link below head over to
curiosity stream comm slash Jones enter
promo code john's upon checkout and get
your first 30 days free of curiosity
stream and for a limited time annual
subscriptions and gift cards are 40% off
cuz tis the season that was new it I
didn't expect that when I took this on
so save your revenue stream with
curiosity streams now it's not but thank
you again to curiosity stream for
sponsoring this video I appreciate it
it's in 1917 have you seen it what did
you think about it in case you already
have but if you haven't what is a war
movie that completely brought you into
it and made you feel like you were there
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]